[Music]
[Applause]
Scott Hastings former NBA player nuggets
TV color analyst he was on site for game
one with the Lakers and the nuggets
before I get to that do you still hold
an NBA record
uh Dan you know I do and I know you're a
bit proud of me although you try to try
to act like you're not uh for Slugs like
me in the NBA
we grasp at any straws we can hold on to
all right let my audience know what NBA
record you hold
well I'm at the other end of the
spectrum of Chris Paul and I on the NBA
record of most consecutive games
without a steal but there's two there's
two parts of this record that's
impressive okay one it's 54 games
two it went across three different
seasons
so
that right there that that
listen I've got kids that love me I have
I have I have four children that love me
and and none of them were old enough to
ever see me play really so they just get
to see the cool pictures of you know me
blocking Dr J's shot or you know Michael
Jordan or whatever
um they don't know about the record okay
yeah
I do hey I feel a little pride of that
listen you know
you know I held a little pride to that
um and then I think you started 19 games
in your career
12 years you started 19 games that is
that the fewest game started by somebody
who played 11 years
and I'll be real honest with you I
actually am very proud of the fact that
I played 11 years averaged like two
points and was never waived I mean I
mean I mean that's kind of hard to do I
mean right you know what you were Scott
you were the heart and soul of the teams
that you played on you know you know I
really was yes lunch pail guy first in
last out you know took care of your body
PA that was a whole different time all
right let's go back to last night if
you're the Nuggets how do you feel about
getting that win
um that was very typical to be honest
with you of of a number of wins this
year if Denver has a in my opinion an
Achilles heel if you will
um is
when they think the game's gotten easy
they kind of go
um and I thought and I've seen him do
that before where they're up 15 18 20 24
and all of a sudden here comes the
starters have to come back in and rescue
and if you look at the numbers are one
of the best closing teams in the NBA
throughout the the season
um the problem is you're in the Western
Conference finals and you're playing
against one of the best if not arguably
the best team the last third of the
Season all of the NBA uh and that's a
dangerous recipe the good that came out
of it in my opinion you were talking
about this going into break a while ago
that there are coming back into break
with hashimura coming over and they did
this and and they said had a little
success I got you
um they also showed their hand of what's
going to happen for game two and instead
of that coming out of game two it may be
shock and Denver and themselves for the
big league I think Denver just got 48
hours to prepare for hachimura on Joker
instead of instead of Anthony Davis yeah
that's a great point if uh you were
going to describe the Joker's game to
somebody who hadn't seen him
I'm gonna give you two stories I went to
vladi divots it was probably Joker's
second year of starting or playing quite
a bit and I and I could see him every
night I mean I've I've called or been
involved in every single game uh of
Joker's career and and I went to plotty
because he reminded me of plotty and I
asked him I said and this is a halftime
I said father you're the only guy that I
remind him of and he goes well he's
already better than me this is like his
second year in the league before he got
all the accolades we're in London
playing a game and Isaiah Thomas will
play with Detroit I tell him for the
game I said watch this kid I'm I think
this kid's gonna be the best player
that's ever played uh for for the Denver
Nuggets uh I said he reminds me of vladi
I don't know maybe a younger suppose but
let's be honest Dan you you were
covering the game oh there's my daughter
see a little Mr Patrick there you go
only on The Dan Patrick stuff
um
but I said Isaiah watch this guy because
I think he's the best ever going to play
for the nuggets and I said see my job
and we came back and put him on the show
in the third quarter and we said who do
you think he goes you reminds me of
Magic Johnson
comparisons of that uh from an early
part in his career and and I would say
this
remember when uh anybody comes out
that's good Dirk Nowitzki came out and I
remember the draft I was working for
Turner during the draft and everybody
said well he's a Larry Bird he's a Larry
Bird type all these guys get compared to
guys until
they do what they do and what Joker's
doing and now it's time for everybody to
start comparing you know themselves a
joke I don't think he's like anybody
he's got a little magic he's got a
little bit of Bill Russell rebounding
wise he's got a little bit of touch of
of a Tim Duncan who by the way was his
favorite player growing up in Europe
um he's he's Nicoli jokic he's I'm
telling you that we had dead history on
my radio show yesterday already said
he's the best best nuggets ever played
Dan this was in the Hall of Fame yeah I
told people that this is a great time to
be able to watch him play because he's
not a highlight guy he's a game guy and
there's certain guys who are like that
that you watch the game and then you go
okay I get it because if you don't it's
like Kawhi Leonard you watch Kawhi
Leonard and you're going all right no
highlights but watch him during a game
and you go okay I get it controls the
tempo and I think Joker does that we're
talking to Scott Hastings the Nuggets TV
color analyst former NBA player uh I was
also wondering about this with the
altitude when you play in a you know
where you're going to be playing in a
series in a city like obviously Denver
uh is there less of an impact or more of
an impact with the altitude on the
Lakers
uh I think there's more and I think
statistics have got to proved that
through the year and the analytics of
blood science and and stuff like that
um
I I will say this I don't know if you
guys have talked about this I thought
last night was one of the if not the
most important game of the series one
delayed won every game in the series
this is going to be the only game either
team either team but Denver last time I
looked doesn't have a guy with 20 years
on his legs but it's going to be the
only team that everybody's going to be
wrestle because now every game go that
every game now goes every other day with
travel in between games two and three
and traveling between games four five
five and six whatever and I thought it
was important for Denver to win the game
by hooker by crook
um because now it's going to be fast and
furious and I think
that side's better with guys that are in
their you know mid-20s than than late
30s
you played well at least you were at
games when Jordan played when bird
played when magic played
um
any any favorite story you got a story
out of any of those three
man I I yeah I'm gonna tell you one
quick one this this Jordan's Jordan
right Jordan still Jordan 30 years later
Jordan still Jordan uh I'm with the
Miami Heat I'm an OG I was on the
expansion team and we're playing in
Chicago
and Jordan comes off a pick about 16
feet elbow extended I come up heads he
pulls up a jumper I catch and block him
hey it goes out of bounds baby bang horn
blows I'm getting subbed out so I go to
the bench and I'm thinking
this black Michael Jordan jump shot
sit down not a peep I don't get I don't
get a pat on the butt from the coaches I
don't get a you know add a boy you woke
him up you woke him up I don't I don't
get nothing I get down and sit there get
some water get a towel around my face
sit down still nothing now and now I'm
doing I mean Scotty
I finally get up after sitting down the
bench for 30 seconds and I faced the
whole bench you know I'm staying on the
court I said tell Michael Jordan to get
that
the whole bench in including the
coaching staff
fall out in the middle of the game now
we're expensive team to 115 games they
fall out in the middle of the game
because somebody is set up hey let's see
how long it takes place to just say
something
for blocking the shot so yeah that I
don't know listen I I played a Great era
uh uh you know Charles and I have had a
lot of fun with the TNT stuff and we had
some rivalries but he was with Philly
and I was with Detroit uh I got to play
against bird I've become okay friends
when Kevin McHale took over from
Minnesota I got to talk to him all the
time
um I played the Great era
played I got to watch some and you were
covering those games yeah and you know
it was some of the greatest individual
and teams that no we'll ever play period
you are second all time
I think with fewest starts yeah Paulie
minimum 500 games played in NBA history
Scott Hastings has 19 starts that's
second all-time fewest starts to Scotty
Brooks 680 games played Seven starts
okay and I would have been a better
coach then Scotty Brooks oh come on
there okay
no I'm just kidding Scotty's good dude
uh but but uh somebody can look it up I
think that's probably 18 in one of my
starts
better yet don't look it up and let's
just say that yeah for future
appearances yeah 81 and it's 19 starts
not bad not bad huh you're still doing
it though still entertaining yeah Dan
you got such a special show my daughter
and now my cat has jumped up on my lap
so I mean only on The Dan Patrick Show
good to talk to you we'll catch up with
you again 90 of my day and I want a
national
thank you Scott
Jinx nuggets TV color analyst former NBA
player he uh was a member of the 1990
NBA champion Pistons